[Music]
well tonight is the highly anticipated
premiere of American crime story Versace
and I think a lot of people actually
forgot that he created some of the most
iconic dresses of all time yeah no one
can forget that Jennifer Lopez deep down
Grammy dress and Liz Hurley safety-pin
dress just to name a few and while the
house of Versace clearly lives on the
fashion designers tragic death and all
those affected by it clearly resonated
with the cast shortly before 9 o'clock
a.m. this morning today
the call was received or shots fired
Gianni Versace was shot on the steps of
his Villa that affected real people who
are still with us and have to deal with
this being a huge trauma and tragedy in
their lives
Glee's Darren Criss plays Andrew Cunanan
his gruesome crime devastated the
Versace family and the fashion world
eats he covered the funeral in Italy the
mourners came by the hundreds to Milan
from Princess Diana to Elton John to
Naomi Campbell Versace's family
criticized the project but Penelope Cruz
says Donatella Versace gave her casting
her blessing and she said to me if
somebody is going to do this if
somebody's going to play me I am very
happy that is going to be you Ricky
Martin who plays Versace's lover Antonio
D'Amico says he consulted with him often
during filming when I said - so tell me
how did it work how did it feel how did
you feel and and he went through a lot
of ups and downs and he shared with me
dark moments of his life that I will
always be very thankful because he
helped me a lot and Versace he's played
by Edgar Ramirez what's it like the
first time you look at yourself in the
mirror and you've made the
transformation - Versace
it was very strange because I've never
used prosthetics before so it's it felt
very foreign a lot of the series was
shot in the old Versace Mansion which
was turned into a luxury hotel we fed
off of the energy of the house that it's
so Johnny still today